And of course if we have some super long light paths that are combinations of
these that obviously the rate face or the recursive ray tracer cannot take this
into account.
Why is that?
That's the big question.
Let's go back to the elimination equation and imagined that I do think the
diffuse surface,
what do I do?
I try to emphasize this earlier,
but I will emphasize again that I take the perfect reflection direction.
It doesn't matter if it's diffused or specular.
I take the perfect reflection direction.
Well,
if I do this,
I have no idea about the surrounding soft,
the object.
I have no idea what is.
For instance,
the buff,
this diffuse pain.
If there is some red object,
I don't,
I don't shoot the rate there in order to get some indirect illumination,
so I will have no idea about the surroundings of this object.
No.
If I switched to global illumination,
however,
there is this integration and integral part of the integration is the income,
the income ingredients and how I can integrate this over the hemisphere is
basically sending samples out in every direction in this hemisphere love.
If I do this,
then I will know about the surroundings of the object.
If there's a red wall or a red object in nearby or the desert nearby,
then I will have samples of the incoming light and therefore it will appear in
the color of the object.
This is fundamental.
This is the very important way to understand why ray tracers are missing these
effects.
Now let's talk about the real deal.
The real physically based BRDF models.
How does it diffuse?
I feel like it looks like this.
So Fr is the BRDF Omega,
Omega prime or incoming and outgoing directions.
X is important on this object
and these are probabilities.
Now this is weird because I'm used to formulate,
so if I talk about this,
you've shinning,
I just seen l.
Dot.
That does,
that's a formula with variables and this.
This is a freaking number.
What do I do with this number?
It's one of our pie block.
Does this even make sense?
Can someone help me out with this?
[inaudible] so this one of our high needs that if this is a scalar,
it is probably to distribution is a scaler.
Remember that this is the distribution of the possible outgoing direction.
So imagine this
scenario up here or you have an incoming direction and if I have a completely
diffused material,
it means that it will diffuse the incoming light in every direction.
So all outgoing directions on the hemisphere have the very same probability and
if they have the very same probability,
then this should be a number than the whole BRDF Cynthia number because whatever
directions I specify here,
I will get the same problem
and I can scale this one over.
Pie with a role which is the IRB Gulf,
the material,
because not a little materials reflect all lights.
In fact most or if not all of the materials we know absorbed some amount of
light.
So this is again a number.
This can be way of like dependent because it depends how much you have sort on
the rep channel,
how much or new channel.
But this can be potentially zero and then you have a black body,
something that absorbs everything so you can call it that you can,
you can change the color of the object.
If I'm not using the right term specs,
I'd like to remain intuitive.
So the Obo is going to give it a color of the object
this weekend specifying no.
Zero.
Okay.
The next question is,
is this a probability distribution function?
Of course it is.
Why?
Because it's because it integrates to what?
There are some other rules that we're going to disregard with respect to
property to distribution functions,
how much does it integrate into this interface?
To what?
Why?
What does the engineer guys say?
Well,
one of our pie integrated from zero to Pi.
What does it mean?
I have a rectangle that is,
that has the heights of one over pipe and it has the width of Pie.
What is the area of direct title?
Let's multiply these two sides.
So it's eight times via is Pi these one over Phi,
just multiply by two and do get one.
So this is indeed
a problem into distribution function.
Good to go.
What about specular brds.
He says these are what describe mirrors.
Okay,
how can I write such a BRDF?
It's a bit trickier because it is fundamentally different than just diffuse
materials.
Why they don't diffuse incoming lighting.
All possible actions.
What?
What is possible is only one outgoing direction.
I see only one thing in the mirror,
not the mixture of everything like on the walls.
Okay,
so this means that one outgoing direction is going to have a,
probably do have one and every single other choices have a zero probability.
So this is indeed a probabilistic model that can be described by a delta
distribution.
That's a distribution means that one guy has a problem to deal with one and
everyone else says zero.
So it's like and actions in a dictatorship.
Is this a problem?
Is the distribution function?
It is,
but I put an asterisk there because I'm going to talk a bit more about this,
but let's,
let's say for now that it is because is this is one for one incoming direction
and zero everyone else.
So we have the wonderful
you're looking for
and there are also glossy.
The rds,
we haven't been really talking about this in the first lecture of mine that it
was some BRDF which was called spreads on one of these images.
But I asked you to forgets his term.
He needed the glossy is the mixture of the two.
So it is not like a mirror but it's not like a completely diffuse materials.
So there is some view dependents in the feels materials.
The APP completely independent bureaus are completely dependent.
So it's like a mixture of the two.
It is possible that there are some loss in materials in this scene.
Can you find them?
Okay.
Raise your hand if you see at least one.
Hmm.
Okay.
Um,
yes,
a couple of the cupboard.
Excellent.
Yes.
Anything else?
Just Charlotte.
Me?
Yes.
You mean this?
Oh,
the floor.
But the cooking,
the cooking Fieldglass slow.
Those little,
oh yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
That's awesome.
Awesome.
So there is Spanish samples that I think the question would be what is math
philosophy in this scene?
The better this will be,
the better question.
And the people you are sitting here is also flossing.
It is a bit fuel dependent,
but it's modern era but it's not completely diffused.
And it also transfers the costings.
So it has some diffusivity.
Okay.
Next question is if it looks good,
but the mathematician guy asks,
how accurate is this?
Oh,
we have this two images.
One of these is generated by means of global illumination solving this equation
and the other one is a photograph.
Do you know which is which?
Raise your hand if so.
Okay,
one person.
I'm going to,
I'm going to spoil all the [inaudible].
Okay,
so look at this part.
So this is the difference that you can see for instance,
because they is the actual box that that's the guys put together at the Cornell
University and you cannot only see the box in the photograph,
but what is next to the box.
Whereas in global illumination,
the surroundings and not model just the Cornell box itself.
So we can go blue eyes.
Yes,
this can be distinguished from a photograph,
but if you look at the actual scene,
it is very,
yeah.
And if everything is perfectly implemented,
then this is so close to physical reality that it is literally
indistinguishable.
So this is really amazing that we can do this.
Whatever you see out there in the world,
we come up with this equation.
There are exceptions because there are wave effects such as diffraction and
stuff like that,
but these are very rare.
I mean there are butterflies looked away because of interference and then these
effects.
But 99% of what you see can be model did this equation and the rest can be
having more sophisticated methods.
So back to this period question,
what is the dimensionality of the rendering of equation?
Okay,
let's try to think it through and it will see so less for just for now.
Imagine that I should rape out from the cabinet and I hit the diffuse object.
I need to sample this hemisphere exhaustedly this is not how I will evaluate the
algorithm,
but technically this is what I need to do.
All possible outcome directions have the same probability.
So I need to shoot these outgoing raise,
many of them.
Now I will hit more diffuse objects after the first bounce and I have to
exhausting this sample.
All of these as well.
Yeah.
And if I take this other way,
I also have to do this and so on and so on.
And so until holiday balances,
we have concluded previously that we have to take into consideration and
infinite number of boxes.
So this is definitely very difficult because the incoming light that I am
something the hemisphere for is another good question.
So imagine that this tell hi,
you can insert another one of these equations,
but that equation will also contain this and this.
And that's a matter of rendering equation.
So it's,
it's an infinitely large sequence of the nipples.
Therefore this is easily a dementia.
Now I've told you before that this is also singular.
This is not such a bad thing,
but this is because of the of specular brds.
The specular BRDF is some kind of the data distribution and Delta distributions
are not really functions.
So in,
in,
in signal processing,
you may have studied this and the first thing that they tell you about this that
this is not a function.
This can be defined in terms of the limit.
So you can for instance,
imagine like a Gaussian curve and you start pushing his Garcia Clara from two
sides.
Therefore this is going to be a larger and larger and thing are getting
response.
Would you do this until you have an infinitive things?
Right now if you check it for the properties of a function,
you will get something that has nothing to do with the function that's,
that's a singularity.
There's an infinitely quick channel from zero to one in there and we need to
handle this somehow because we can,
we can take into consideration functions.
We can integrate phantoms.
So let's just solve this trivially by handling this specular reflection and
specifically what does it mean?
This means that if you have an incoming direction,
you're not going to play with probabilities.
You are just going to grab like in a ray tracer,
you are just going to grab
the perfect reflection of direction as allowed contraction,
no probabilities.
Wow.
The beauty break,
we have some scenario which is ray tracing because of different things,
because the image you created by means afraid facing,
but there's literally one ray of light being reflected here many times.
So awesome.
These are experiments with lux render.
We will try and things off like this.
A big layer of during in the course
and the lottery example.
It's amazing what we can do with these aggregators.
Yeah.